hello everyone Ola Henrickson here like  all of you I'm absolutely devastated how  the corona virus has swept our world  it's taken away valuable lives and  impacted the global economy in a very  negative manner therefore it's so  important that the government around the  world and all of us come together to  commit to financially support the  development of a vaccine for everyone we  must act now because it's the only way  to get out of this dark tunnel on May  4th  we can all stand united with our  governments and take the pledge to help  find a cure for the corona virus let's  go on in the meantime and celebrate life  and each other  you